you
we're getting people from all over
California and all over the world who
are they just have driven far to come
see these way
it's pretty much the biggest against in
newport beach or in southern california
because that hurricane was so strong
that it produced and that's what
produces heat waves or the pro Hawaiian
surfer prepared it in one area pipeline
still tis very dangerous with in doubt
don't go out and you'll know your limits
don't get in over your head once you hit
the water and you get out there you can
find yourself in trouble the day that
the swell energy arrived for probably
the biggest waves I've seen you working
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook